vous l'avez vu dans le titre j'ai
participé à un projet de web
documentaires avec arte c'est trop stylé
merci beaucoup arte suspect l' homo
digitalis alors c'est un webdocumentaire
de cet épisode de dix minutes et genre
ça parle du transhumanisme de ce qu'est
homo sapiens le fait que l'humanité
change énormément change très vite et
que du coup bah voilà il ya plein de
repères ton en train de perdre est
inventé et donc ça parle de ça à travers
plein de thématiques l'amour l'amitié
les loisirs le travail etc
donc voila c'était vraiment un actif à
faire vous allez sur promo digitalis
point tv pour les épisodes
il ya aussi un quiz qui l'ont fait en
fait parce qu'ils font un partenariat
avec une équipe de recherche pour
essayer d'en savoir un peu plus de
comprendre un peu nos habitudes comment
nous on voit tout ça et je vous mets le
lien du test dans la description en jeu
c'est qu'ils visent 10000 participants
au moins pour fin janvier
voilà je sais pas si on va y arriver si
on arrête c'est cool parce que ben plus
on donne d'infos et plus justement ces
organismes là nous aide à comprendre
nous aide à faire des documentaires
comme ça évidemment c'est un sujet qui
me tient à coeur et vous savez pourquoi
si vous aviez matériel vidéo sur la
transformation cybernétique si vous
l'avez pas vu c'était devant le lavoir
je sais pas si je vois vous montrer des
extraits de à quoi ça ressemble si j'ai
droit vous montrer des extraits ça
ressemble à ça quand l'intelligence
artificielle nous aura dépassé
deviendrons-nous les chatons domestique
de noro beaucoup ont peu partout sur la
planète
les pionniers de la technologie planche
déjà sur une solution
l'amélioration des performances de notre
cerveau ma collègue allemande hélène
farès est allé voir sur le terrain
comment tout ça fonctionne
[Musique]
bienvenue dans homo digitalis à partir
de quand nous ne sommes plus de
véritables êtres humains aujourd'hui on
a parlé du cerveau comment dans le futur
on va pouvoir interagir avec lui comment
l'améliorer
comment le modifier en plus ce qu'ils
étaient style et ses quais bas âge et
avec des professionnels du son de la
voix guitare pour la poser ma voix
parlée plus parce qu'évidemment un
documentaire ou un web documentaire
d'arte et on ne parle pas avec la même
vitesse
une vidéo youtube est ce que j'aimais
dans ce projet c'est que en fait ça ne
présente pas les trucs en mode web c'est
hyper dangereux
waouh c'est hyper cool ça les présentes
et c'est un petit peu à nous de se faire
notre propre opinion moi j'interviens
parfois sur certains sujets ou en gros
ben je donne mon avis où je donne une
idée ou où je réagis à certaines choses
j'ai pas écrit sur le fond du
documentaire mais en tout cas voilà
c'est un truc super intéressant et j'ai
hâte d'avoir vos retours j'ai eu
beaucoup de retours déjà via twitter 5,4
de gens qui ont beaucoup aimé mais voilà
il manquait plus que vous sur youtube
j'espère que ça vous plaira aussi
n'hésitez pas à me dire dans les
commentaires je les lis tous voilà love
peace on sera très bientôt pour nouvelle
vidéo
alors je la fais ce que j'ai à déclaré à
la fin c'était c'est ça